alright welcome everybody on Wednesday I
forgot to film a video for friday i
usually go on a rant or share something
and i forgot to do it and christina
reminded me so I said you know what and
i owe you guys a video i'm going to
start a new series maybe we'll see how
this one goes coffee time with Alex so I
just kind of hit Alex families he's
working for my dining room table he's
gonna share a message my message today
is understand how other people express
love it all started yesterday I was
having a conversation with Evan
something very deep about how I want my
fiance 22 to show her love for me it all
really stemmed from when I grew up in a
household where my mom made a lot of
food and that is how she expressed her
love like she would just make awesome
food and she was cooking she was like 12
and so what as I was growing up that was
like the standard for what I would want
in my partner right and so when rose and
I started dating that wasn't something
that she was just really passionate
about and and it was it was something
that we had difficulty with like I want
her to do it she likes to cook right
like but it's not a priority like of all
things it's not the most important thing
basically I had this difficulty there
was this like cognitive dissonance I
don't think I'm probably using the right
term here but the idea that there was
the separation between what I wanted her
to be like versus what she is like and
and where she does show her love Evan
and I we had this whole discussion about
that I can't you know you don't you're
not you shouldn't force people to do
things that they're not most passionate
about and so my issue was well you know
if you're in a relationship you should
you you know you do things that you're
not happy about but make make the other
person happy right it shouldn't be all
selfish and all that not that was an
itself as she does a huge amount of
things that just like for you know that
she knows I hate doing and I'm not
passionate about and she's like these
things need to get done the point in a
deeper thing was how each person
expresses
love and being able to understand it and
appreciating it my mom expressed her
love through cooking and it was amazing
and but that is not the only way to
express love and that is not the only
way to build to have a connection with
rosanna she expresses her love with a
variety of ways kicking me in the butt
sometimes because she knows something
needs to be done that I don't do but
it's important for me i express my love
to kicking out a lot of butt kicking and
Alex Isla if and he's not the one
dishing it out unfortunately so I
actually had a really really deep impact
for conversation after Evan I spoke with
Rosanna and I realized that she was
having these complexes that I was
putting pressure on her that she needs
to be you know perform at a certain
level right of like cooking all the time
and being this thing when she's she's
not passionate about that she's
passionate about many things and and me
accepting that there's so many more
beautiful things that she does for me
and our relationship and she was she is
a person that putting her in a box and
limiting her or projecting what I think
she should be like is just gonna cause
us trouble in the long term I do believe
that there should be a balance right
like you shouldn't be in any
relationship where you know you do
everything for the person but the person
doesn't write like show love a
reciprocate or do things but it it also
it also should be like understanding
what's important to them and if you're
lucky and you're with the right person
they'll do the same and Rosanna has done
that Oh throughout since the beginning
like I did not date Rosanna and then we
got engaged because she's like you know
chef boyardee or sorry whatever the
equivalent is right like a famous shells
like this incredible person I started
dating her boy idea you're laughing at
that
it's amazing i love you keep going sorry
um go go go okay you killing my momentum
and you stop me I'm like I'm mom she
wasn't she wasn't that I loved her for
who she is all the beautiful things that
we went through and all that it's easy
to get wrapped up in your head about
what your needs are and what you think
is important verses really what's what's
at the core of what makes them special
and beautiful and it wasn't it wasn't it
wasn't it wasn't the cooking or whatever
was right she makes great food too mind
you like I don't want to talk her she's
made beautiful dinner she made me take I
love sweets on my birthday it's actually
on facebook right now oh by the way I'm
tried 1030 as a side note so that was a
big thing today today I'm to anything
with it no yeah but today days yeah
tomorrow tomorrow I think it's coming oh
it is okay so so great with october
fourteenth is when it's coming up sober
13s when's my birthday it helped me
having a discussion with rosanna first
apologizing and having a discussion
about understanding her better as a
human being and loving her for the way
that she expresses her love towards me
you know the thing that she does and she
takes care of that maybe I don't even
appreciate and having that discussion
with her made her think about all the
things that I do for her and how she's
appreciative of that it's very easy to
want to mold people around you to the
way that you need it and on your terms
and what happens is either you know they
will feel stifled or oppressed or the
and they'll do it and sooner or later
might explode or you have lots of fight
or they'll just walk away a person is
not two dimensional so you know
something when I was younger I I pursued
things you know like I want I had a list
of things the person that I want to end
up with his has to have these things if
he does it or I mean she does in or he
doesn't whatever who's watching this
right Dennis this is my list yeah then
they don't meet that criteria and that's
that's that's short-sighted the best you
can do is be a better version of
yourself every day and if you're lucky
they'll do the same acknowledging and
understanding what my fiance how she
expresses her love
makes me appreciate her so much more and
makes us happier now she wants to she
wants to make awesome food she wants to
do all that but I enjoy cooking too i
just realized i made a dinner yesterday
made to course dinner yesterday there's
a lot of fun actually how you're raised
or whatever the traditions are that set
standards for what it means to for it to
be a whole or whatever it is right
whatever what a relationship is what a
husband and wife are what a girlfriend
and boyfriend are with two girlfriends
are what two boyfriends or whatever it
is right are the foundation that you
that you build you know all your
understanding of the world it's
sometimes limiting and so my foundation
was that she needs to be a certain way
and she needs to do this and this is how
she's gonna show her love but its its
its its weak sauce its weak sauce it's
not it's not it's not you know you need
to add a little bit of a cup a couple
Calvin's in there you need to add some
spiciness to it it was a scary feeling
actually because yesterday it was pretty
tense between Evan and I write it got
pretty it got really heated because like
we have we had we have has stronger yeah
but the point was what was scary for me
was I started questioning everything
about how where I put my value and where
I series Anna's value and my friends
valleys not just resent it affects
everything right and just about being
humble and about coming to understanding
from her perspective and she does the
same and your friends are you people
important to you that have a big impact
I think we'll do the same if you make
the first gesture if you work on
yourself and you try to understand
people better it tends to be that
they'll they'll they'll give that love
back and it's a beautiful thing cool
well a couple things I want to add to
this first off you know and you guys be
able to learn from alex's store i think
is the most important thing not just
Alex you know sharing his personal life
where you guys can able to like pick
teach you a lesson from it I think one
is whole thing like I need a video I
said Alex do you want to be on a video
right now let's film something I gotta
send to christina is again we're gonna
talk about I don't know you pick a topic
okay and just like when opportunities
come to you
jump on them and go for it even if it's
scary and you don't know what you're
gonna do yet you know this discussion
came up because with Alex's mom you know
she showed her loved through food and
understanding that people express their
love of different ways and him expecting
Rosanna to show the same level of love
and care that his mom did through food
is an unfair guilt that she would carry
around forever and would continue to be
a source of fighting now Rosanna needs
to love Alex and Alex into lovers Anna
but how somebody chooses to express
himself will be different you know maybe
rozonda expresses herself through being
closed through hugging cuddling
snuggling whatever or some other way
right she's gonna love him just as much
you know just as strong but just express
it differently and there's not one right
way or the other but to put an
expectation someone's going to do and
express themselves one way is just
setting yourself up for failure and if
you look to like the next generation you
know they have kids they're gonna have
like 25 kids or something like that like
two football teams you know you get
ready resentence heaven if the kids are
sick alex is going to want to cook for
them and give them food and give them
soup and that was how my mom cheated me
to like I'm sick here's some chicken
noodle soup homemade with like spinach
and all this up to make me feel better
where if Rosanna is connecting through
cuddling that she's gonna want to lie
down and cuddle with them until they get
better right and not this one coach is
not better than the other it's still
love and so you know for the people in
your life how they show their love is
important and recognized and it's not
going to be likely the same way that you
do it fear for for them and so you know
even this morning Alex came in on his
birthday and offered to make me food and
I said yeah that'd be great because I
you know I always like a good some good
food but also it's how Alex shows his
love so I didn't want to reject the gift
because not because I didn't care so
much about it right like right yeah
awesome but more you know I didn't I
want him to feel like his gifts are
being accepted at the same time me and I
made me breakfast so Alex maybe two eggs
and eggplant parmesan and a not a bagel
croissant quest sounds like a big-ass
breakfast that I'm not used to annina
made me a couple eggs as well so I
finish out his breakfast and then I ate
Nina's breakfast as well because she
expressed his love through food and if I
didn't eat that I'm rejecting her love
too I don't give love through food you
know i will give love through
conversations and confidence and doing
activities and spending time together
and so just having that awareness if
you're in any kind of relationship if
it's a personal relationship of business
relationship how somebody likes to show
affection or love or feel respected is
likely not the same way that you do it
so being conscious of that will have a
really dramatic positive impact on your
ability to have those relationships
because otherwise you're putting unfair
expectations on the other person which
isn't fair for either of you and then
you know I want to give a big I want to
clap it up for Alex 24 for coming on and
talking about this cuz we talked about
this yesterday and he was all against
this at the start I make sense like it's
something that's been value system for
30 let's change that overnight you know
look you know so we fought it and then
and then goes home and has a
conversation Susannah and then thinks
about it now today is embracing it and
encouraging you to as well so like how
quickly Alex can kind of take feedback
and start to try to make a positive
difference is good so hopefully you can
learn from one of those three messages
when you have an opportunity go for it
understand how people express love in
different ways and you know if somebody
calls you out on your stuff on your BS
then receive the message and then go
spread it to others that's it I like
this what do you think coffee time with
Alex might be a series we'll see how it
goes
we get to delve into his personal life
every week Sarah Palin's of people there
appreciate feels a live session that
would have been god I know it is like an
hour and a half I was quality guys that
was intense yeah thank you guys for
watching a question what do you want to
ask uh yeah uh is there a value system
that you are attached to or maybe you're
projecting onto others that now that you
think about it it's not as important
dead silence is it Wi-Fi i should go
yeah you know why i feel like i need to
go a little deeper with it now okay
because i liked it because how this all
start a lot of it started because i was
ranting that the food is not important
that food is not important that the love
is important focusing on the right
things in business in a relationship
people focus on the small insignificant
things compared to the deeper core issue
the issue is love in this case right the
issue in a relationship is love not food
you know if fruz anna doesn't express
her love in any way that's a problem
there's something going on there needs
to be fixed but she's going to do it to
her own way and for those univers Anna
she's a extremely loving person so when
you're looking at a situation in a
relationship or in a business like is it
really what actually matters is this
important this is what you want to fight
about right like this is really that
significant that you're going to fight
about it where if the person has a
positive intention that's what usually
Trump's like that's what you want to
look at first and maybe it's your own
shortsightedness your own value system
that might need a little bit of a jolt
and it's not like it's not that same
cooking is wrong it's not that cuddling
is wrong it's just how somebody chooses
to express themselves and recognizing
that is the bigger game as opposed to
try to force somebody to change to be
more like you question was what is their
value system that you have you base your
decisions on and maybe you're projecting
onto other people that after watching
this video you're like well maybe I'm
not in the right maybe there is
something deeper that I need to
her out let us know leave in the
comments thank you guys so much for
watching continue to believe that was
good thank you i was watching the camera
you're wondering i will see you soon
guys